-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden attacked
former President Trump yesterday
for calling his opponents
"vermin"
and said, quote, "Damn,
he shouldn't be president."
Of course he shouldn't
be president,
but that's what you're using
as evidence?
How about the four years
he was president?
[ Laughter ]
The White House yesterday
released the fifth
National Climate Assessment.
And if you're wondering
how things are going,
they said
don't expect a sixth.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Mike Johnson
yesterday defended former
President Trump's false claims
that the election was stolen
and said, quote,
"I take him at his word.
I do believe
that he believes that."
Which is absolutely
the smoothest way
to call someone crazy.
My wife does that to me
all the time.
I'll be like,
"Hey, I'm a great husband!"
"I believe
that you believe that."
[ Laughter ]
Former House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
denied claims yesterday
that he elbowed
Republican Congressman
Tim Burchett in the back
and added, quote,
"If I would hit somebody,
they would know I hit them."
I assume 'cause his fist
would bruise.
[ Laughter ]
The House...
[ Laughing ]
Just, like...
Just, like, a weird case
where I don't know
if we needed to see it.
You know, I think if we all
just, like, in our heads,
pictured a bruised fist, not one
of them would be that weird.
[ Laughter ]
Bummer is we sent one
of our writers out
to just punch a wall.
[ Laughter ]
The House yesterday passed
a temporary
government funding bill
that does not include any aid
for Ukraine or Israel,
or, frankly, the US.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
said in an interview yesterday
that he can't vote next year
for former President Trump.
Wow, that could really hurt
Trump's chances
in West Virginia.
[ Laughter ]
The US Postal Service yesterday
reported a $6.5 billion loss
for the year,
but they got a bold plan
to make it all back.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, it just takes one.
Just takes one sucker.
Alaska Senator Lisa Murkowski
criticized Utah Senator
Mitt Romney in a new interview,
for eating salmon
with ketchup.
To be fair, that's the spiciest
dish you can get in Utah.
[ Laughter ]
The restaurant chain Chili's
yesterday released an ad
that features a new version
of its jingle "Baby Back Ribs,"
performed by the R&B group
Boyz II Men.
Sounds like Boyz II Men
has got "billz II pay."
[ Laughter ]
Says the guy
who did a Verizon ad.
[ Laughter ]
[Bleep] on my high horse.
Former Vice President
Mike Pence yesterday
released a new book titled
"Go Home for Dinner."
Look for it wherever tables
are a little crooked.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right, Mike Pence
released a new book,
titled "Go Home for Dinner."
I guess it's no surprise
he thinks eating out is a sin.
[ Laughter and groans ]
Bruised a couple of fists
with that one.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, New York state
education officials
are reportedly considering
dropping the Regents Exams
as a high school graduation
requi-- requirement, excuse me.
While Massachusetts high schools
are considering
dropping the breathalyzer.
[ Laughter ]
And that...
was written by a dude from
Massachusetts -- Scollins!